all right before we get into all the
news we have tonight on this show we're
never gonna forget that Hillary Clinton
we now know rigged the primary against
Bernie Sanders we're not going to forget
that her exoneration was written before
the investigation was even near-complete
on the private email server we're not
going to forget that a phony dossier
bought and paid for by Hillary Clinton
with Russian lies was used to get a FISA
court warrant against Carter page even
though the FBI never verified the
information on this show we're gonna
stay on this story until we get justice
now on to tonight's developments now we
have two shocking reports both from the
New York Times and the intercept they
are raising serious questions this hour
about just how far the deep state will
go to damage president Trump now
according to these reports American
spies met last year with an unnamed
Russian who was thought to have ties to
Russian intelligence now the American
officials were interested in recovering
powerful cyber tools that had been
hacked
but this Russian person quickly claimed
to have quote compromising material on
President Trump now the New York Times
does report that the American
intelligence officials say they were
only interested in retrieving the NSA
cyber weapons but the Russian was
eagerly pushing anti-trump information
which included 15-second video of an
American businessman in a room talking
to two women according to The Times
there was no way to verify who was in
that video and the American spies
thought it was incredible now the Times
reports that the American officials
eventually agreed to pay this shadowy
Russian $100,000 but instead of turning
over NSA hacking tools
he gave them quote unverified and
possibly fabricated information
involving mr. Trump and others including
bank records emails and purported
Russian intelligence data now the
hundred grand was supposed to be the
first installment of 1 million dollars
that they were going to pay out which
was down from 10 million that the
Russian originally was asking for now
The Times also notes that since the
phony anti-trump dossier altered by
Christopher Steele came out last year
there have been at least four Russians
with espionage connections and they have
tried to sell damaging information to
political operatives spies and
investigators and also according to The
Times member Cody Shearer along
Time Clinton a lie who would write a
second fake news dossier quote he has
been criss-crossing
Eastern Europe for more than six months
to secure the purported compromise which
means compromising material from a
different Russia so there's a lot of
information to take in here let me try
and connect these dots for you
US intelligence officials paying
$100,000 to a Russia with purported ties
to Moscow ends up giving them unverified
possibly fabricated anti-trump
information now where that information
is who has that information we don't
know now the CIA tonight is strongly
denying the information being reported
by the New York Times and the intercept
and the NSA reportedly declined to
provide a comment to the intercept and
on top of all of this we're also
learning that at least four other
Russians have been shopping around
compromising information by the way I
thought they liked Trump and longtime
Clinton friend Cody Shearer is literally
going all over Europe trying to dig up
damaging dirt about presidents from from
a Russian here's what it all means
tonight Russia is doing everything they
can do to spread lies about president
Trump and Democrats are more than happy
to accept it because they'll do anything
to damage the president and I thought
this was the horrible thing to do it
though we spent a year investigating
collusion with the Russians but we have
discovered real collusion and these new
reports are offering up even more
evidence that we hadn't seen before now
we already know that Hillary Clinton and
the DNC they paid over what 12 million
dollars to fusion GPS they hired the
former British spy christopher Steele he
created that dossier filled with Russian
government lies and propaganda salacious
material well Clinton did that with what
intention she wanted to impact the
general election didn't matter if it was
truthful or not and those two memos as
they were covering here the FBI and DOJ
then they used the salacious unverified
dossier of Christopher Steele to get a
warrant to spy on the Trump campaign and
their associate Carter Paige and
according to the memos the dossier made
up the bulk remember the Grassley and
Gramm memo made up the bulk of the FISA
application and then the FBI James Comey
they never bothered to verify it and
they used it and they go before a FISA
Court in an effort to spy on Carter
Paige and the Trump campaign they never
said Hillary Clinton bought and paid for
it and it's not verified as they should
have and as we told you about on Friday
politico's reporting that former White
House chief strategist the ban and he
may have been picked up by FBI
surveillance Mike Carter Paige was being
spied on and a State Department official
actually admitted in an op-ed that he
was sharing anti Trump opposition
research from friends of the Clintons
with the dossier creator Christopher
Steele this is all an unprecedented
abuse of power the Constitution is being
shredded before your eyes civil
liberties are being severely violated
remember the Fourth Amendment protection
against unreasonable search and seizure
and yes in spite of what the media is
telling you and downplaying it is bigger
than Watergate and as we have been
reporting a lot more information is
coming out every day now take a look at
the side of your screen I think this is
a small scandal so far 14 officials at
the DOJ and the FBI have either been
fired reassigned demoted or quit they
want to get out of there and there are a
lot of others who are involved in what
is being exposed but simply being moved
around the bureaucracy that's not going
to be good enough that's not going to
solve the problems all of these
officials they all need to be
investigated and those that are guilty
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law so this never happens again
also new tonight senator Grassley and
Senator Graham of the Senate Judiciary
Committee they're now demanding answers
from President Obama's former national
security adviser Susan Rice now they
discovered a partially unclassified
email that she actually sent to herself
on president Trump's inauguration day
and rice through this email appears to
document at January 5th 2017 oval office
meeting between President Obama former
FBI director James Comey and former
Deputy Attorney General Sally Yates
regarding Russian interference in the
2016 presidential election and her email
rice notes that President Obama
apparently told Comey and others to
handle things quote by the book really
and Grassley and Graham are struck by
the context and the timing of this email
and they have now sent out a series of
questions for rice to answer by February
22nd
now while Republican memos are providing
damning facts and evidence about deep
state government corruption well the
Democrats they desperately trying to
cover up the truth they never wanted you
to see this information and they're
trying to change the narrative they put
out their own counter memo and on Friday
President Trump sent the Democrats memo
back to the House Intelligence Committee
with a letter explaining why because it
contained classified sources and methods
that could jeopardize national security
and of course the media predictably
ignored all of these facts and they're
attacking President Trump for being anti
transparency but of course we know
they're lying the Democrats were clearly
setting a trap of the president they
wanted him to release classified
material about sources and methods the
White House didn't fall into the trap
and the president wants to release the
memo Democrats they have to make the
necessary edits not the president
remember the Republican memo did not
contain classified information it did
not reveal sources and methods so why
can't the Democrats play by the same
rules because the facts aren't on their
side and for rigid left wingers in this
country and members of the media that
are complicit you know that are claiming
this is you know all a plan to block the
Democratic memo not at all I say release
that memo they clearly didn't read the
White House letter or listen to the
House Intelligence Committee chair Devin
Nunez and new notice is saying like
we're saying that he wants the memo
released
I want it released take a look we
actually want the Democratic memo out we
think it's ridiculous on the face of it
we think it's very political about how
they tack mice myself they attack
chairman Gowdy they turn Carter page
into some super secret Russian spy they
talk about how Christopher Steele is a
is a really really good source what do
we know that he lied to the FBI so we
want this out we don't know why they're
not in this weekend redacting it so that
we can get it back to the White House of
the president can declassify it all
right there you have it for Republicans
this whole issue has been about truth
and transparency and for Democrats the
left-wing media is all about playing
politics we're going to have more on
that in a moment but first the Winter
Olympics in South Korea began late last
week but not without some controversy
now after Friday's opening ceremony
well members of the echo chamber swung
in a full gear to heat praise on a woman
named kim yo-jong who just happens to be
the director of propaganda for the rogue
dictatorship in north korea and the
sister of one of the most brutal
oppressive dictators in modern history
Kim jong-un that didn't stop the
mainstream media from fawning all over
kim yo-jong for showing up at the
opening ceremony shaking hands with the
south korean president and calmly
watching the opening procession CNN fake
news the whole network they ran this
headline quote Kim jong-un's sister is
stealing the show at the Winter Olympics
and Reuters led with the caption quote
North Korea heads for diplomacy gold
medal at Olympics and not to be outdone
the New York Times writes Kim jong-un's
sister turns on the charm
taking pensive spotlight and the New
York Times also tweets without a word
only flashing smiles Kim jong-un's
sister outflank vice president Mike
Pence and diplomacy and the Washington
Post not to be outdone called Kim Joe
Young the Ivanka Trump of North Korea of
course is glowing coverage continued on
TV take a look athletes from the North
and South Korea marching on the same
team
waving reunification flags more history
just a few seats away Kim Jong Un's
sister right there behind the vice
president she's on hand for the Olympics
as well in a historic moment South
Korean president moon jae-in shook the
hand of kim yo-jong the sister of North
Korean leader Kim jong-un the sister of
Kim jong-un shook hands warmly with the
South Korean president in the VIP box at
the Olympic opening ceremonies but North
Korea is stealing much of the limelight
Kim jong-un's sister landed at Incheon
Airport earlier today three days of the
world's media running after the sister
of North Korean leader Kim jong-un and
still we know very little about the
woman who has stolen the headlines at
the Pyeongchang Winter Olympics all
right if that's not bad enough the media
also goes after vice president Mike
Pence for refusing to shake her hand in
the VIP box we'll have more on that with
Joe concha later in the show but take a
step back and remember the woman that
the meat is applauding is the director
of propaganda for a government that has
let's see murdered around
or hundred thousand political prisoners
and what some are calling concentration
camps and these camps have been in
existence since 1982 and as we speak
between 80,000 and 120,000 people are
still imprisoned in those camps
including men women and even children
and according to a 2014 United Nations
report well over two hundred thousand
people from around the world have simply
disappeared never to be seen again
inside of North Korea and don't forget
there are three Americans currently
being held hostage in that rogue state
now the Kim jong-un regime has also been
responsible for the recent death of the
American Auto warmbier who was
imprisoned and sentenced to hard labor
for allegedly stealing a poster but last
but not least millions of people are
currently starving inside of North Korea
roughly 30 percent of their population
starving all while this little despot
Kim jong-un lives a life of luxury and
his sister enjoys a prime seat at the
opening games of this year's Winter
Olympics and despite all of this the
mainstream media continues to praise kim
yo-jong now it's pretty disgraceful but
we shouldn't be surprised it was the
same mainstream media that praised of
course President Clinton for saying his
nuclear agreement with North Korea it's
a good deal for the American people
they'll never get nukes
well that didn't work out and if you
don't learn from the past you're doomed
to repeat it and that's why the media is
a sad and despicable broken record and
finally tonight speaking of bad plans
remember the plane loads of 1.7 billion
in dollars in cash and other currencies
the Obama administration stupidly gave
the Iranian mullahs chanting death to
America and Tehran
well now we're finding out that the
rogue regime is using a lot of that
money Washington Times reporting that
the US government has now been able to
trace some of the money given to Iran
and determined that Tehran is using it
to fund the terrorist group Hezbollah